Bro, I'll be real. The She's like categorically in the wrong
here, okay? She's like categorically in the wrong. And something
about this like actually breaks my heart where she's like, "You're
really going to press charges on me." Like actually kind of breaks
my heart a little bit that she looks betrayed. It's like there's
like a chemical response there in the brain that I know. You
can see her like looking like I didn't hit you. Come on. Come
on. Did she bailed out? No. Um Ice Poseidon has not given Kimmy
a new credit card yet. So Zena has not gotten bail yet. Okay.
But as soon as Ice Poseidon can get to paying for that credit
card, as soon as Ice Poseidon can get to paying for Zena's bail,
he'll he will do so. Okay.
Are you guys ready for the Cena stuff? Let's check it out. All
right. Let's go give it a look.
[music] Let's go give it a look.
Let me see. We've got logs. Okay. logs from the 29th.
Like, own up to it and people will respect you 10,000 times more.
So, Shiv is getting pressed about going over to Zena's place.
Okay.
Or her coming over to his place. Whatever. Yeah, you went over
to Zena's place on Thanksgiving to SP to save money. I spent
20k on toys, got pegged and dipped. Are you happy now? Own up
to what? I spent the night at her house on Thanksgiving to save
money. I spent 20k on toys, got pegged and dipped. Are you happy
now? I don't I don't know. Okay,
that's a bit of an overshare.
Bit of an overshare.
All right, there is some really goofy here when you figure out
that Zena has a strap on and the most prominent dick she uses
is a cast. Okay, it's a mold of Shuy's dick. Okay, so there is
a possibility that Shuy is one of a handful of men on earth to
have been in the ass with his own dick. Okay, when you think
about that, you really think about it, it's pretty up. Okay,
that's that's crazy stuff. I'm just saying not many people can
make that claim.
You know, he had that same look on his face he always has when
he's getting plowed. Just totally
totally zansed out maybe, possibly.
So, he's I think he's just talking about leaks and that have
come out or he thinks are going to come out. He spends like some
time talking about basically guys if you see if you see anything
crazy it's AI all right it's AI until we have heard otherwise
very in line with him being an engineer from Prometheus. This
is all in ISIS Discord it looks like. I think um anything that
makes me embarrassed is AI. All right. Yeah, dude. I think he's
very concerned that there are some some videos of him discussing
stuff, some recordings of him discussing stuff or possibly some
videos of him doing stuff that would not make him look masculine.
Okay,
bro. I wasn't groomed. I just roll my eyes and say, "Yeah." Uhhuh.
Uh-huh. Yeah. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Yeah. Okay. I already did. I'm
positive. Go get tested for HIV. I'm good with everything. Is
she pregnant? No, bro. If she's somehow pregnant with my kid,
I'd build a rocket ship and fly into outer space. [laughter]
Shuy beats Elon Mus to Mars in totally unexpected. Okay. He'll
use the same engineering knowhow that he used to construct his
van, drill holes in the panels of his van. Okay. In the top of
his van. He'll use that. He'll use that same entrepreneurial
spirit to get to Mars ahead of Elon Musk. Let's [__]
go. Okay.
All right. I I had these logs that were just like a prelude to
Oh, he was talking to Zena. He was talking about Zena and then
I think he went over to Sorry. Then I think Let me just check
this one more time. So, I get this timeline correct. And then
yeah, Shuy went to her house again
to get the rest of Oh, I actually don't know where they Sorry,
I still don't know where today is, but this is where he went
to her house to get his like he went to go get this or something.
He went to go get his uh his costume or something. Okay. And
I don't know if he stuck around. I don't know what was going
on. He was calling Zena and he had a clip from yesterday where
Zena was saying slurs on his stream that he had to go and mute
for. Okay. All right. And without further ado, let's get to the
actual video.
Okay, let's get to the actual video. Cuz really the content here,
in my opinion, is going to be commentary from other people and
his interview with the cops after the fact. Okay, the fight stuff's
very short. The fight stuff's barely even a thing, but
got pegged and dipped. He tries to drop it like he like he stands
on that. That's That's the worst thing. He you can always tell,
okay, when you have like an embarrassing thing and you try to
go like, "Yeah, that happened. Whatever, man." Like, you try
to minimize it and you know it's something like it's something
like, "Dude, it's like he did the food shops play." Okay. Yeah,
I d off to Let's stop talking about it or something. Like, don't
just don't say it. Either stand on it proudly or just go I don't
talk about that stuff. One of the two, man. You can't go
Is dipped a thing? No. Dipped is saying I left. I got He's like
I He's like a hero. He doesn't look at explosions, okay? But
he also doesn't look Zena in the eyes when she penetrates him.
Okay. He got pegged and then walked away. He got pegged and walked
away. He didn't look back at the woman who pegged him. Okay.
Got pegged and dipped the out.
He did not cuddle after. He was like, I only I only [laughter]
Maybe Zena is right. Maybe he's got a magic and unfortunately
for him, it's all in the shape. So he he's given Zena that power.
She's stolen his magic from him. So when she him in the ass with
his own, he uh he is now obsessed. All right. He's like, "I just
came for dick and then I went and then I left." That's a very
Zena coded thing to say. That's what he said, by the way. That's
literally what he says there. Okay. I just came for and then
I got out.
That's That's literally what he said.
That's That's a crazy thing to say. That's a crazy thing to put
into text.
But here we are.
Get on.
Get off. >> Fight me, I'll fight you, too.
>> You want me?
>> You want to fight me, I'll fight you, too. Uh, Zena
always does this, by the way. This is a very This is like a very
consistent Zena behavior. when she sees somebody is recording,
she will immediately start saying things that happened before
but probably didn't happen, right?
Like that's that's what she does every single time when she when
she sees somebody recording, she'll immediately go, "Uh, yeah,
well, you ripped me and now I'm doing this." It's like, "What?"
So, she immediately says something that happened before, which
is very funny. Okay. And with a lot of the things, they end up
being absurd. Maybe Shuy was doing maybe Shu is getting physical
with her. Okay. But I just I think it's very funny that she does
that anytime she sees a phone recording her.
>> And then this is this is her outside. >> I mean,
it's on video.
>> All right. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on.
Now, I'll say there doesn't appear to be a punch on video. They
They aren't getting physical. But I don't know.
Again, Zena doesn't have BPD. Uh people in the chat saying Zena
does not have BBD. Zena is bipolar. Doesn't have BPD. She's bipolar.
They are different
>> I mean, it's on video.
>> Oh, this is going to be brutal.
Bipolar one or two? She said, but I I forget which one. >> No,
it's not. I threw your boxes.
Wait, wait, wait. Um, can we walk up to
>> Get off.
>> Get off. >> Fight me. I'll fight you, too.
>> You see that fish? >> You want your butt plugs?
>> And then she grabbed her butt plugs and then tried to
say, "That's my property." And then she's like, >> "Oh,
wait, wait. Is Nick here? Oh god, this is Nick live." Oh, that's
sick, dude. Nick's everywhere now. Nick's all over the place,
>> dude. That's crazy.
>> you're streaming through the whole thing, right? Or
no, no,
[__] loser. The [__] happened throughout
your entire history? Okay. I don't think he posted this one.
Do we have this one? The one in the apartment.
Loser. Get the out of here.
>> [__] loser. The [__] happened.
Throughout your entire history together, >> Has she ever
threatened you with a
>> Okay. Hold on. Hold on. I want to go back and watch
like this full bit. So, if this is just the interview of this
POV, we're going to go watch this whole interview. Okay.
It's from a stream today. We're going to go check it out. But
I want to see if I can find that video. Give me a second. I might
have it in my Discord. Give me one
If he posted it, I've got it in my Discord. So,
hold up. Hold up. Hold up. Hold up.
No, I don't think so. No. No. He didn't post this one. This one
is like unique that he showed a NYX. Okay.
He went live to the police interview. The VOD is up. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. I know. That's why we're going to watch it. Even if he
Yeah, even if he had here's the VOD. So, yes, he went live and
it was like already at the police interview. Okay, so
I'm just, you know, I'm
we're we're at one of those times, one of those moments in time,
okay, where we can just watch this. We can just enjoy. We can
just watch it. And then afterwards, there's a little bit of Darius
commentary on why he thinks they broke up. And I think Darius's
thoughts here are, uh, here's proof of Zena being violent. Now
all of my crimes are okay. It's like, brother, your crimes are
totally one-sided and on camera in a way that Zena's crimes aren't.
Okay? Like, you spitting like a llama over 20 ft at her face
repeatedly like seven times. That's all on camera. That's assault.
You don't get to assault somebody just cuz they get in a domestic
with their [__] partner. That's not how that works,
bro.
Watching a body cam. You know the people. Well, it's not a body
cam. It's shy cam, but it would be like a body cam. Okay. He's
basically doing his own body cam.
>> Not darn up. Well, not for his cases at all. No. Tannon
bomb. In terms of shaden fraud, yeah, sure. In terms of his enemies
are having bad times, sure.
But like like realistically,
nah.
He's It has nothing to do with his
I live? Chat Zena just got arrested.
>> Chat, no. No way, chat. Zena just got arrested. [snorts]
>> Cuz I pressed charges on her for assault
>> cuz she assaulted me. >> Uh yeah, that link worked
for me. Don't don't post those links in chat though, okay? just
I like I I'll be real. I don't even know if we like have to protect
Zena's name anymore. It's just been said so many times on so
many streams. We probably don't, right?
Like I I'm sorry if I I try to be like careful about it, but
her name has just been said on stream in full so many times across
like the entire CX network.
You know what I'm saying? Oh, it doesn't work for you? Yeah,
it works for me.
I was just saying like that's technically her arrest record.
We'll get to it.
>> What a surprise. Good bait. It's not bait. I mean, she's
literally in that cop car and I have the video,
but I can't show the video because I'm streaming off the phone
that I've recorded the video on.
Dang, you can't see her in the back.
Bro, I'll be real. She
She's like categorically in the wrong here, okay? She's like
categorically in the wrong. And something about this like actually
breaks my heart where she's like, "You're really going to press
charges on me?" Like actually kind of breaks my heart a little
bit that she looks betrayed. It's like there's like a chemical
response there in the brain that I know.
I know.
Oh man. I know.
Here. Hold on.
I mean, it's on video. >> She's like, you can >> I
drew your box.
>> You can see her like looking like I didn't hit you.
Come on. Come on.
Is she bailed out? No. Um, Ice Boseidon has not given Kimmy a
new credit card yet. So, Zena has not gotten bail yet. Okay.
But as soon as Ice Boseidon can get to paying for that credit
card, as soon as I beside can get to paying for Zena's bail,
he'll he will do so. Okay. I Why doesn't Ice Poseidon run his
own bales uh bail bonds thing? Why? He should. He absolutely
should just invest, Paul. Okay, just get get is it a bondsman?
Just get your bondsman accreditation or whatever the Okay, it's
just an investment in the future for your content model. It would
make a ton of sense.
Yes, CX bail bonds. Yes, absolutely.
>> He looks like a bail bondsman. Okay, that's I think
that's coded anti-semitism. Okay, careful with that. Very careful
with that. Wait, wait.
>> Yeah, I I Man, I feel bad.
I understand where Zena's coming from with some of the stuff.
So, I just I Man, I feel bad, which is too bad. I should I shouldn't
I really shouldn't. They just took her away. Try all I tried
to do was pick up my come pick up my Bigfoot costume and my BB
gun and then she destroyed the box
and uh she was just throwing it and trying to steal and [__]
I really man this the sad thing here is
this could be like cooked up. I don't see any real physical abuse.
They're like fighting over a phone. That's super not like domestic
violence in my opinion. Not like arrest one of the partners domestic
violence. I think Zena's obviously capable of domestic violence.
Okay. But the fact that she was like arrested here straight up
that all I'm saying is listen balance of probability. Okay, I
think she probably threw a punch at Chu too. Okay, probably just
based on previous experience,
but in terms of beyond a reasonable doubt, there's no punch shown
really in the video that I saw. Okay, but I haven't gone frame
by frame yet.
It's possible. And she did throw the thing down there and they
were like getting physical pushing back and forth when he was
recording. But that's all like I don't know if that's call the
cops worthy
man.
So anyway, all all that to say it could come up that this is
kind of cooked up >> and then she could come out. >> Um
so this is the number I was tell this is the number I was telling
you about for victim services. If you just feel the need to reach
out to somebody um that's our number, right? And that'll be your
case number for today. But um can I get your first and
>> is it so they're probably in Texas, right? Does Texas
have the kind of laws where they have to arrest somebody on a
domestic violence call where they have to remove somebody from
the house?
Cuz I think that is in some places that's the law, right? Basically,
if you get a if you get a domestic violence call, you have to
like take that person in and process them,
right? You have to take one of them in and process them. But
I don't I feel like in Texas that can't be the case. Also, what
I think is the other thing is probably if you get a domestic
violence call and you have a record already, they're probably
super likely to grab you, right? Like, if they look and they
see that she's got like the the charge for like the previous
charge for shooting at somebody with a with a well, it doesn't
say paintball gun. It's like discharge a weapon in direction
of people, right? I'm guessing she just probably had to be taken
away.
So, I don't know if this is really necessarily like talking about
guilt. She would have had charges because they would bring her
in, but it doesn't mean she's guilty. >> Yeah. Sean, S
h a u n
sharky. S h a r k e y. >> Mr. Sean Sharky, >> February
28th, 2006. >> Current address.
Oh, hold on. Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. Do we
want to There's a little bit before this, I think. Like, oh,
which which direction is it? Hold on. Oh, no, no, no. I think
it's I think it'll be after. Okay, cuz based on the light the
light here. When does Nick show up? Nick shows up and it's dark
out, right? Hold on. Let me go back. Yeah, Nick shows up. It's
dark out. So, this will be after. We can go watch Nick's VOD
and watch their conversation as well. Okay, check it out. All
this all just content to him. I think he's slowly turning into
Darius. Uh, no, he's not slowly turning into Darius. They He's
not the same. He always did the content thing. Shu's always been
about the content, okay? He's always been about the content.
He This isn't like Darius at least was like wildly irrationally
in love with Zena. Like there was something there that he wasn't
doing it in a calculated way. Shuy does it a 100% calculated
way. Like it's not like the this like totally crazy love thing,
okay?
It's it's not. So it's it's very different. It's very different.
I don't know, man. True. Darius's content is Darius's content
is not I'm saying that Darius is like out of control. Shuy is
in control. Totally different. He just said GG Zena. He did as
she gets like as she gets driven away. He does say GG
[__] up. Gave his address just now. It's going to
unmute. Oh, please don't leave it muted. You Oh, you definitely
gave your address and you haven't unmuted yet.
Oh, you come on, bro.
No way. How long does he stay muted? in jail.
What the
>> Is that Is that Tazo?
Dude, dude, the kick IRL, sorry. The kick IRL like ecosystem.
These people just naturally migrate to drama at all times. They're
just like, "Oh, some Cena going down. We got to drive." It's
like constant scavenger hunt in Austin. Okay. Like if something
crazy is going down in Austin, they just all show up
>> Yeah. [laughter] All right. >> And of course,
Tazo's the first one there. How incredibly expected. The only
guy who's like really really on the ball all the time. He's like
always there. He he was basically leading the sc the scavenger
hunt the whole time. He finds this immediately.
>> Where's uh Zena? >> She's in jail. >> What?
Really? She got taken away.
>> All right. She's already gone.
>> Yeah, she's gone.
>> Oh, there's Nick.
Nick Lee right behind Tazo.
Okay, this makes me realize that um I think we Oh, I don't see
the GG Zena clip yet. There is a clip of him saying GG Zena as
she like gets taken away. >> Currently employed. >> Uh
no, I'm not employed or I guess I'm self-employed or something.
>> You have emergency contact. I can have >> emergency
contact. Uh is it ne Oh, yes. Uh Paul >> Paul Denino.
>> He like literally always says his emergency contact
is Paul Denino.
>> The best part is they like they act or they ask they
ask for his address and he's like, "Oh yeah, sure. I got that."
>> D E N I N O
>> and a good phone number.
>> Uh good phone number for Paul. Um, I don't think
>> I have it. Um,
>> wait,
wait, hold on.
Sorry. I hate to keep going back and forth, guys. They They're
like shooting a movie for like >> they're making like an
Ice Poseidon movie over here and then they must hear about this
and they want to all go run
>> I think uh we still on track to do the uh the
>> We see Zena arrested getting spammed in chat. I just
want to see this happen organically cuz they are like 30 seconds
away from wherever Zena and Shuy are. They're like 30 seconds.
They're walking distance. They literally jog for like 2 seconds
and they're dead.
>> Yeah. Perfect. Okay. >> Oh, you got >> Well,
yeah. No, I just uh I'm trying to drive myself because I
go next door. >> The cops are arresting. Oh my god.
>> It's literally next door. What the? They're doing something
totally unrelated. It's literally next door. Okay. Hey, I thought
this was way more intricate or elaborate than it was. They're
just like they're they're literally within two seconds long.
>> I guess I should
>> Yeah, you didn't get the pops. Okay. >> Hopefully
I not Well, maybe not. I'm chasing [laughter] you. I get shot
by
RP Chad.
>> Respect the commitment to the content.
>> this is Wait, wait. >> It's like night crawler
but kick condition. [laughter]
>> this is fun, right? >> Oh, get on the street.
>> Is it here? Let me see.
>> The is the Alamo. >> Oh, wait. An alim next to
Alamo. Maybe >> he's Alamo.
Jesus Christ, man. Oh, that's what you're talking about. Jesus.
Do you want me just to take your
>> Okay, go for it.
>> Okay, so it must be other side then.
>> Wait, is that a shoe parking van? Wait, is that the
van? I can't tell.
>> Is that just a truck or >> trying to mix in the
uh trying to mix in the Nightcrawler music? Okay.
>> Okay, they do end up getting there. I Sorry. I just
thought it was really funny that they they like hear about this
and they stop what they're doing entirely and
they just run over to record this.
Tao is covered in fake ISIS's fake blood because he was ISIS's
corpse in their
Wild.
Wild. Okay. All right. Sorry. We're back to Shuy. I had to see
why they ran over there or how they got there so fast. Okay.
Got it. Got it.
>> This is within four minutes of Shuy going live. By the
way, he's giving them ISIS's address here.
>> How long have we been together? Well, >> I guess
her name right. >> Yeah, I guess on and off for like maybe
6 months technically, I guess you could >> Do you share
any children? >> Do we share any children? No.
>> Thank God. >> Um, so next portion is a bunch of
uh questions that may or may not apply to you. If they don't
apply, they don't apply. Um, we'll go to >> Oh, the
the victim questionnaire. This is such I get that he's doing
this for content. This is like a weird look. Did she physically
abuse you throughout the course of the relationship? It's like
all of the domestic violence and technically men can be the victims
and like all of this. But I Dude,
I'm sorry. This is one. This is toxic masculinity at work. Okay,
somebody call Piers Morgan. This is my toxic masculinity at work
right now. Okay. I would never be on a stream answering questions
about whether or not I was. Okay, sorry. Not happening. Not stream
content. Not masculine. Not a masculine moment >> today.
Did she strike you? >> Uh, yes. >> Open hand or closed
hand? >> Closed hand. >> Or both.
>> Maybe both. But I just vividly remember a closed punch
coming at me. >> Okay. Did she push you? >> Throw
anything at you? >> Grab at you?
>> Pull at you? >> Bite you? >> Strangle you?
>> Strangle? That's like choking me or
How long uh approximately did all this go down? >> It went
down for like maybe like 10 >> No. How long ago? >> Oh,
maybe 20 minutes ago. >> Did her actions cause you physical
pain when it was happening?
>> Not necessarily. No, but
I mean, >> does it hurt now? >> No, it doesn't hurt
now, but >> strangling. That's like choking, right? >> Prevent
you from calling 911 or >> Oh, yes, she did. >> How
did she do that? >> She grabbed my phone and threw it.
Were you on the phone with 911? >> Uh, yeah. Or it was
it was calling them, but maybe they hadn't answered yet.
>> Um, did she use or threaten to use a weapon against
you?
>> Does she own any weapons that you're aware of? >> Um,
just like a taser, pepper spray. That that not Yeah. >> Does
she have concealed carry license? >> Uh, no.
>> Did she threaten you if you called the >> Did
she threaten me if I called them? Uh, no. No, she didn't. >> Has
she hurt you before? >> Has she hurt me before? >> Um,
I mean, she's like,
>> she doesn't use enough lube. Okay. She does. That's
That's his real answer. He's got to like he's got to take the
actual answer in his head and he's got to like recalculate.
Okay. He doesn't want to put that on tape, >> you know?
Like tried to like kind of I didn't get physically hurt, but
she has like tried hitting me before. So, if that makes if that
counts. You >> ever call the police for that? No, I didn't
call the police for that. >> Has she ever threatened me
to kill you?
>> Do you think she was using drugs today? >> Uh,
I don't think so. No. >> Are you interested in an emergency
protective order? >> An emer a protective order? >> Yeah.
Do you know what that is? >> Yeah. Yeah, I would like to
have that. >> You understand that? Uh, we will since you
requested one, but it's up to the judge whether that one gets
issued or not. Okay, >> that's fine. >> If it does
get issued, someone will contact you. >> All right. >> Is
there anything else that worries you about your safety? >> Um,
no. No. No. Not that I can think of. >> Uh, about how tall
are you, man? >> How tall? Like 6'3 or 6'4.
>> About how much do you weigh? >> 150 probably.
>> You know how tall she is? >> Actual stick. >> I
think maybe 411 I think. I don't know. >> About how much
does she weigh?
>> Like 130 maybe.
>> And besides your little injury on your hand, anything
else that hurts on your >> No, nothing else that hurts.
>> Where else does she hit you? >> Just like body
really. But I'm wearing like a padded motorcycle suit. So,
>> uh, I have to double check. Do you want uh EMS? >> No.
No, I don't need EMS. >> All right. Uh, this next Are you
or her currently in the military? >> Uh, no. We're not
in the military.
>> And you share no children, right? >> Yeah. No,
we don't share any children. >> Uh, these next questions
are going to be yes or no. They might be repetitive. They might
not fly, which we can get to them real quick. This is not just
today, but throughout your entire history together, right? Okay.
Has she ever threatened you with a weapon?
Has she ever used a weapon against you?
>> Has she ever threatened to kill you?
>> Wait, are we doing this all again? What? >> No.
Not that I No. >> Has she ever threatened to kill your
>> You just asked if they had kids. Okay.
>> Do you think she might try to kill you?
>> Well, she
maybe. Yeah, she could. I mean, she's kind of insane. So, >> does
she have a gun?
>> Oh, come on. No, not that I'm aware of. >> Does
she have easy access to a gun? >> No, not that I'm aware
of. >> Has she ever tried to strangle you?
>> Is she violently or constantly jealous of you?
>> Okay, that one that one I could probably that one is
a forgivable answer. Okay. >> Does she control most of
your daily
>> Has she ever fortunate to have you want
come on, man. >> Yeah, sure. Yeah. Yes. Yes.
No. She totally she didn't use enough lube. And then I said stop
and she wouldn't stop and she said I she could tell I liked it.
It's It was terrible. It was terrible. I'm sorry. This is again
Someone called Piers Morgan. This is toxic masculinity. Okay.
He literally just said to this cop on stream, "Yes, I was right.
Yes, I was right. Yes, I was. Yes. Yes, I am Shuy. I am." >> Well,
yeah. Sure. Yeah. Yes. Yes.
>> Have you said
>> Wait, did he look at his chat?
>> Hold on. >> Hold on. Hold on. >> She could.
I mean, she's kind of insane. >> does she have a gun? >> Did
he look at his chat?
I think he might have looked at his chat. Hold on. Let me move
my chat out of the way. Let me move all this [__]
out of the way. >> Let me move it. Let me move it out of
the way. Good lord, these eyes are terrifying. How do you guys
deal with >> No, not that I'm aware of. >> Does she
have the access to a gun?
>> No, not that I'm aware of. Has she ever tried to strangle
you?
>> Is she violently or constantly jealous? >> So,
he's looking at the cop now. Let's watch his eyes and let's watch
his
>> Does she control most your daily
>> Had to think about that one. How many How he runs all
of his thoughts, everything he does through a xenop filter. Okay.
He's That's what he's confessing to right there. We had to think
about that. Does she control all of your daily activities?
No. Barely concealed grin. Yeah, he's kind of a piece of [__]
He is >> your fortune to have sex when you didn't want
to. >> Where is he looking? Where is he? He immediately
looks down here.
>> Yes. Is he looking at this? >> Well, yeah. Sure.
Yeah. Yes. Yes.
>> Have you?
>> Dude, even me maniac says, "Look at him. Don't look
at us. Look at him. Look at the cop." Dude, what's the kick delay
like? Well, I think this Hold on. These people are saying right
here. So I do believe that this is caught up. People are saying
yes to that question.
Right. So this is this is about timed correctly. He literally
looks at his chat and he's like, "Yeah, I guess so. Yeah, I guess
so. My chat says I was right." So you know what? That's that's
all I need to hear.
One more time. >> Well, yeah. Sure. Yeah. Yes. Yes.
>> Have you separated after living >> Did we separate?
Wait a few seconds. >> Have you ever separated after you
were living together and then got back >> Have we split
up and then got back together before? Yeah. >> Is she currently
unemployed?
>> Is she unemployed? Uh,
>> well, yeah. I I don't know. She's like a stripper, I
guess. So,
>> has she ever tried to herself?
>> Do you have a child that does not belong to her? >> No,
I don't. No. >> Does she follow you? >> Does she
follow me? Yes. >> Does she spy on you? >> Yes. Does
she leave you for any
>> Well, yes. Actually, yes. >> What kind of messages?
>> Like, uh, >> so if he's going to go cuz I do believe
Zena does this sometimes. Zena's like, actually, a lot of people
do this. People get emotional and then they make threats and
then they go, "Oh, no. I gave myself plausible deniability."
It's like, you won't like what happens if you do that. And then
people be like, "That wasn't me like threatening you. That wasn't
a threat. What do you mean? That was a promise." It's like, no,
that's not how it works. Saying it's a promise doesn't mean it's
not a threat. Okay.
That's not how that works. Actually, that wasn't a threat. It
was a promise. It's not a defense from threat uttering threats.
It is just not. >> I'll burn your clothes, for example.
>> Threats that put you in fear of your life or serious
injury. >> Oh, then no. >> And you don't want victim
services come out today, correct? >> No. No, that's fine.
This last portion is your opportunity to write your written statement.
obviously it's it's your statement. I can't tell you what to
write. If something doesn't apply to you, it doesn't apply. But
the more information you can give us, uh, the better. >> Um,
this top portion right here is just saying that you can read
and write English that the statement is true and correct to the
best of your knowledge and you understand that making a false
report of the crime is Texas. If you understand that, you can
sign in and date there. Just go through the questions as they
apply. All right. Today is the first. It's the first,
>> bro. I don't, man. I think this is so This is so weird
that, bro, he has like one tiny scrape and the cops got called.
I think that's crazy. I think what he wanted was he wanted a
legal order, I think he understands exactly what he's doing and
that he knows if he makes this call and he asked for a protective
order, he gets it. He probably went through the same process
with Zena and Darius, right? He knows that he if he wants a emergency
protective order after a call for domestic violence, I think
he gets it. I think he just wants Zena away from him and he wants
it like court mandated that she stay away.
I think it's like totally calculated. >> There's only 30
days in November. >> Classic classic Shuy. >> Wait,
where am I?
>> Shuy is like the battered wife in this situation.
Okay. He's like he's going to get this protective order and then
he's going to violate it himself. He's going to message Zena
one night at like 2 a.m. and be like, "You you got that good
for me, daddy?" That's what he's going to send. He's going to
send that message to Zena at 2:00 in the morning. Okay, that's
what he's going to do. It's crazy. He is like the
obsessed person in this relationship is
I know. I know you didn't mean it when you hit me. It's a crazy
soundbite. Well, I wish hadn't said it or thought it or is I
wish I hadn't pondered the orb and seen that he was going to
do it.
it's unfortunate. >> What led up to the assault?
I was trying
pick
up
How did suspect assault you? Punching,
>> I want to know does he have some clip that makes it
look like it wasn't just mutual like they weren't becoming mutually
physical? Cuz I think you basic basically Shu is going to get
gas lit by his audience and like you you're totally correct.
you have all the video, you have everything. And it's like, no,
he's got basically video that shows some mutual, you know, scuffle.
Doesn't show a punch and that it's like a he said, she said.
I'm sorry. I don't think he has like a slam dunk here. I don't
think,
man. Yeah, he's being yaslit. Absolutely. He's being yaslit right
now by his audience cuz they hate Zena. Oh
>> What injuries do you have as a result of the assault?
cut finger. >> Basically nothing happened. >> How
did you get each injury from
>> He did show what he said was three videos of her assaulting
him. No, he showed one video. I thought it was just one video.
Or they cut up cuz we watched it. Like this is as far as I can
tell. This looks mutual. Okay.
Is her picking something up. She's turned around and he's got
his hand on her and he's saying, "Get the [__] off
of me." I didn't actually notice this until you pointed it out.
>> The [__] off me. >> Wait, he starts
recording and he has his hand on her and he's saying, "Get the
[__] off me." He might be doing the Zena thing. Hey,
I'm going to say what happened before this. Then maybe pull the
phone out, but we don't know if it actually happened. Is there
another one? >> The [__] off me. >> Oh,
there's another one in the house. >> Get off me.
>> Get off me. >> Fight me. I'll fight you, too.
>> Get off me. I'll fight. >> So she hits the phone.
>> Crazy ass [__] >> You want your butt
plugs? >> The butt plugs down the stairs. It's just mean.
Okay. That's crazy. Yeah. So there's another video. There's the
other one that he showed Nick, which is I think right here. So
he shows Nick this one eventually. Okay.
But I I don't see that as like proof of one-sided assault. I
don't think so,
>> Maybe one of the other videos, though.
like for his ass. Yes. Canadian color. What part of this have
you missed?
Shuy.
Okay. Zena has a strap on that is like plug and play for different.
Okay. The she uses is one that's made from a cast of Shu's. So,
as we've already we've pointed this out, we're going to keep
pointing it out because it is funny. Is it is a grand cosmic
irony that he may be one of the very few people on Earth who's
been in the ass with their own dick. Okay. Can't be very many
people. Source. Source that she has like a molded. She said it
multiple times. They've talked about it multiple times. I'm just
telling you.
>> Do you feel physical pain either at the same time of
>> Why would they talk about that? Why would they talk
about that? They're insane. They They put their entire personal
lives on stream for fun and profit. It's crazy.
Stop being obscene. No, I have to be obscene. It's like any other
thing, okay? You have to read the actual material. You have to
say the actual thing. You can't minimize it. You have to be accurate.
Okay? You have to be accurate. I don't want to talk about this
stuff. Okay? I This is gross, but I have to say it. I have to
be accurate. Okay? We've seen the clone kit. We have seen the
clone quick kit. We have. It's
>> Yes. [snorts] >> Just the content world we live
in in 2025. Brother's got to eat. Okay. He's got to eat. He's
got to do anything he can to actually eat. All right. It's It's
a rough world out here.
>> Time and date and time is 5:41 p.m. >> All right.
So, do you have any questions for me? >> Uh, no. Well,
yeah. No, I think that's everything. Well, so she went to jail
for assault.
>> Uh, I'm not sure about all the charges.
but basically, she went to jail.
>> Oh, he's got the thing where he puts memes from the
Discord on stream. Damn.
Oh, this can't be hard to add. I'm going to think about it real
quick. Like within the next day or two, we'll see if we can do
this. Okay. Integrating the Discord is a good idea. Got to be
a good >> And so, how would I know when I when or if I
get that protective order? >> Someone will contact you.
the jail should call you regardless once she gets released
>> um to warn me. >> Yeah. Just let you know that
she's she's been released. But, uh, they should tell you if you
get one or not. >> Um, but I would just ask and if you're
Yeah, I would just add they should
>> Here's what she did get booked on. Okay.
So, these guys right here. Okay. Uh, this was today. Assault
causes bodily injury. Family member misdemeanor class A. Unlawful
restraint misdemeanor class A. So, this was them grappling with
each other. And then assault causes bodily injury. He has the
cut. So he can say I was injured and it's an assault. So like
technically this is true. Technically
Who did more physical damage? I mean almost certainly Zena I
guess. Although I you don't really know. Zena could have cuts
too. We haven't seen Zena.
Zena could have like cuts on her hands and stuff. Absolutely.
I don't think that's also that's not necessarily like who assaulted
who. Like you don't get a pass on assault because the other person
did more damage to you. That's not true. That can't be a thing.
could tell you.
>> what's up, Ginger? >> How's it going? >> Anything
up before I get out of here? >> Oh, no. That'll be all.
>> Have a better night. >> Thank you. You, too.
>> Yo. Yeah, I'm good.
What's up? >> Any idea what happened? >> Well, yeah,
I know exactly what happened. I was involved with it all. But
basically, I uh >> We got the Nick Lee interview. No way.
>> Let's go. After cleaning the flower off Kimmy's car,
I just since I was nearby, I I texted Zena. I said, "Can I pull
up and get my Bigfoot costume, which cost me $240."
I obviously wanted to get that and my BB gun. And I just wanted
to see if I had any other clothes inside. >> It's total
views on the VOD, not total viewers right now. Although, I'm
guessing he's got at least 1,000 viewers right now. >> Then
we're going to cut it and we're just going to go back. >> Oh,
look how on the money I am.
>> 1,083 viewers right now. look how on the money I am.
>> So, I went inside to look around and then she wouldn't
let me look in the closet or in the uh washer or dryer for my
clothes. So, I was just like after trying for a little bit, I
was just like, "All right, whatever. [__] it. I'll
just take what she gave me and I'll just go and be the better,
bigger person." And then she tried to block my exit cuz she wanted
to ask me questions like
um like,
"Why did you do this to me? Why did you tell me you love me?
Why did you do blah blah blah?" She just wanted to ask all these
relationship questions that I don't really care to answer. And
um yeah, then I went to the stairwell. I tried to grab my stuff
to leave. And then she again blocked the exit and she kept demanding
answers to her questions. I she blocked the stairwell. I tried
to turn around to go to the other door. She blocked that exit.
I tried to go up to the third level from the second level, but
she tried to pull me down the stair.
I'm sorry. That is the picture where I was like, "Oh, I feel
bad." That's kind of brutal. That's That's kind of brutal, dog.
They are kept winging it in Shu, dude. Totally psychopathic reactions.
Kekw. Really? Really? We're going to c
W Zena's pain for reals.
>> No, I I understand. I get it. >> And then >> Kek
W and Keo. >> She's like, "Fight me. Fight me." Basically,
like, "Oh, you want to hit me? You're going to hit a woman?"
And then um
yeah, she just like grabbed my stuff, threw it everywhere, and
then she tried to start like kind of swinging on me when I was
recording her. And then
>> yeah, she tried to take my BB gun. And um yeah, I don't
know. But >> uh what I guess uh what did they take her
away? What did they say? Or >> they said like family domestic
violence or something. >> They wouldn't believe. Okay.
>> Is that worse than assault? I'm not the >> Okay.
[laughter] Well, yeah. But
yeah, I I was just tired of her, bro. She wouldn't let me leave.
She wouldn't let me get my stuff. And >> if they gone disturbance,
then it would be lesser. But yeah. >> Yeah. But the the
thing is they arrested her because I have a video of her assaulting
me. I mean, I can show it. Um, let me see. >> So, what
do you intend to do? Just uh give them the evidence. >> Okay.
Where do we We got to flip to Nick's POV in just a second here.
>> We have to flip to Nick's POV as they stand here while
she answers questions >> like multiple times. And I did
all this
>> Here we go. Here we go. >> Chat, hold on. Let
me just say go to Nick Le's stream because I I don't have another
phone right now. I'm going to show him the videos on his stream.
All right, just go to his stream real quick.
Oh, damn. >> Let's see here. [clears throat] All right,
so this is one video. >> What's wrong with being on it,
Sean? >> Oh, sorry. the Cash Patel thing. That is me being
exhausted. I got like three hours of sleep. So, we got like the
popping eyes. Okay. This is me drinking like caffeine. I'm being
powered entirely by caffeine right now. Okay. It's the only thing
keeping me standing or sitting in this case. >> What's
wrong with being honest?
>> Then just be honest. >> Then why did you lie to
me? >> Tell me why you lied. That's the only thing I know.
>> Cool. Tell me why you lied. >> Why did you lie
sitting there saying you care about me? >> Then why did
you say you cared about me? >> Please stop. Why did you
say you cared about me? >> This is her blocking the stairwell
>> and I'm just asking her please stop blocking it. >> I
tried to open the door, she closed it. >> No, probably.
>> So, I think this there [clears throat] might be they
ask questions around this, this might fall under some kind of
domestic violence law, right? I do believe because if you think
about it with the roles reversed if Shuy were a bigger guy. If
Shuy were like Darius, okay, like a stockier guy with like a
lot of muscle, you would you would see this like totally differently,
right? Blocking a small woman from leaving. That would be a totally
different it would give you a totally different feeling. That
is like being imposing. That is Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. That is like
that is physically intimidating somebody out of a confrontation.
It's like you're threatening violence to prevent to prevent them
from leaving, from inconveniencing you, right?
Nick having flashbacks when he was brutally blocked by Amaranth.
Yes.
Nick. Dude, Nick is totally on Shuy's side here. Oh my god. This
is the most violent assault I've ever seen. This is like 10 times
worse than what my wife did to me.
>> I just wanted to [__] waste all this time.
Why? >> I don't know why you're doing all this. >> Because
I want an answer.
Oh jeez. Um, and then that's just a little bit. And then this
is the main video, I guess. >> [__] off.
Get off. Get on.
Get off. >> I'll fight, too.
>> Oh. Okay. Okay. Okay. Also, quick update, guys. This
is all good stuff, but quick update. Apparently, everybody's
gone live and like talked about, you know, all of their court
cases in Austin. We have like so much content now. There's content
all over the place. We've got Merk went live to talk about Zena.
Okay. We've got Darius talking about Zena. Everybody's reacting
to Zena getting arrested. All right. We've got and everybody
has court all these people have court cases with Zena. It's just
a content cornucopia. Okay. It's a little late. Thanksgiving
was last week. All right. It's a couple days ago, but it's a
content cornucopia and we're here for it. All right. You want
your butt plug? >> And then she grabbed her butt plugs
and then tried to say that's my property and then she's like
>> you should the whole thing, right? >> No,
here's
>> [__] loser.
>> I don't know. She was just acting crazy and [__]
>> Well, yeah, that's what happened. >> You think
they will put her away this time cuz she has the prior? >> Yeah,
she does. She has she has a assault charge in Bashaw County on
Merc and then she has
>> bruh. Dude, it's it's so crazy that he's like calculated.
Shuy is literally not confident in a single thing in his life,
but Nick's like, "Do you think she'll like get in like in a lot
of trouble? Do you think she'll like actually go to jail this
time?" He's like, "Yeah, here's like my entire legal knowledge
on this." It's so gross compared to how he acts. Look at how
he's talking here with legitimate joy. Okay, he has legitimate
joy in his voice talking about how she's going to go to jail
and every other topic he ever talks about, he's like, "Yeah,
man. Yeah, yeah, I see that. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Bro, are you serious
right now? >> You think they will put her away this time
cuz she has the prior? >> Yeah, she does. She has she has
a assault charge in Bashrop County on Merc and then she has one
here for the paintball incident and then now another one here
for me. So, but no, honestly, I've seen people get arrested.
>> Um, so this is really easy to understand, Riy. Everyone
is weirdly excited for Zena to be locked up forever. That is
entirely explained by Ice Poseidon not liking Zena because she
took uh Kimmy's side multiple times against him and he thinks
that she like Kimmy into hating Ice. Okay, but that's entirely
what it is. None of these people actually dislike Zena. Zena
on like a personto person level is quite a nice person. All right,
like she's she's usually quite nice to people she's friends with
or networks with. She's very good at networking. That's why everybody
talks to her when she doesn't have like a major figure who is
against her in a specific community.
Like she's very good at networking. She's very nice to people.
Big brown-nosing game. I mean, we could call it networking. We
could call brown-nosing. Whatever the but Ice Poseidon hates
like he doesn't like Zena. That's the last thing he said. Ice
and Zena are okay now. Not that it matters. Well, it won't matter
because he expressed it's just like Kimmy, right? Once he's expressed
negative sentiment, you can't reset that very easily. It's very
difficult to reset that. All right. So, I'm just saying this
is absolutely why these people don't like her. They all loved
her before. They all loved her when she was ice besides darling
and setting up events for him. They would have all been kind
to her and they're just all totally clout and moneypilled. They
they don't seek anything else in life. None of them are loyal.
They just all flip on her. >> So many times in Texas and
nothing >> It is different for girls, too. They're going
to be as light as they can be usually, right? >> That's
fine. But hey, maybe I can just get a protective order out of
this and then she'll stop. >> Yeah, that's good. That's
smart. Yeah, >> that's that's all I just want her to learn
her lesson and just not
>> I need a protective order right now cuz I had to show
up for my $100 like Bigfoot costume. That was really critical
that I showed up for my $100 Bigfoot costume. Guys, I'm the one
who needs a protective order. I totally just didn't go here and
start. That absolutely didn't happen. I didn't go here for content
cuz I was feeling like particularly lazy today. Nope. Nope. I
haven't been hanging out with Zena to cause another crash out
for content. Nope. Nope. Nope. >> Bother me. That's all
that I have. So, she doesn't need to get locked up. If she does,
I wouldn't really care because maybe that'll learn her her lesson.
But she could get out the next day. I also don't care as long
as they give me a protective order, you know?
>> Well, what's going on with the movie I >> We just
finished it. It was insane because there's like on both ends
of the street his neighbors with one person with was walking
with their kid and they just all stop and they like formed like
a crowd around it and they're watching, you know, Moyes beat
this watermelon and then there's like this meat and because we
put fake blooded meat and so all this meat and gores just flying
everywhere and then I saw like uh one lady just like cover her
kid's eye cuz I was like, "Holy fuck." I don't think they're
happy with it.
Classic domestic violence incident. Okay. He's He literally This
has had zero effect on him. He's just back to totally normal.
Totally fine. Oh, let's go, guys. >> But, you know, uh
y'all probably distracted the cop calls if they made >> Yeah.
[laughter] Yeah. I was going to say I was like looking at uh
>> that's how you know it's a real domestic violence case.
Okay. Could you imagine these communities? Unironically, could
you imagine any of these communities and how they'd react if
the roles were reversed? Okay. We need the train wrecks thing
right now. Okay. Imagine it was Zena sitting here laughing about
getting Shuy locked up with a dubious video. Imagine if she was
sitting here like laughing about how she was locked up and about
how she's gonna get a Dude, they would they would mass in Austin
and lynch her. Okay. Unironically, dude.
Holy [__] That is exactly the type of she would do.
I'm maybe. But I'm telling you that they would freak the out.
But him doing it to Zena, they're like, "Oh yeah, you had to
do this. You had no other choice." No, they're just all the
bro. The gender thing, the gender lens is like totally ruining
everything.
Get me back. Get me back to like eight years ago, okay? When
apparently none of this [__] existed. These people
and their hate for women like clouds everything they do, everything
they think, everything they say. H It's like the easiest to farm,
too. It's like another Hassan situation where I should I should
just make the the smart choice and be a incel and make money
off of that content. But instead, I'm just going to be an understander.
I'm not going to be a woman hater, okay? And I'm going to be
stuck having an audience that isn't like cultishly devoted to
these concepts.
>> Dream while the cops were here and I saw like blood
on people. I'm like, damn. I'm surprised the cops aren't like
over >> Yeah, you saw Taz it, right? For a >> Did
you see all the blood on his chest? I did. >> Yeah. I was
surprised the cop just like didn't give a [__] >> Yeah.
[laughter] Yeah. I was too, but I guess he just like whatever.
It's >> Yeah, it's Austin.
>> And Paul says he lives in a good area. >> Yeah.
There was there was flower on Kenny's car, right, from what I
did. Yeah. And um the neighbors walked by when I was cleaning
it. They're like, "Oh, did someone vandalize this car?" Like,
do do we need to like watch out? Is there like some, you know,
>> you did it, [laughter]
On any given stream, you can play homeless or kickstreamer. Okay.
Is that a homeless guy walking like suspiciously like belining
towards them? Nope. Just a kick streamer. Nope, that's not a
hobo. That's a kick streamer. Oh, we're safe. We're safe. >> Call
M. >> You could have just called Merk, bro. >> What
do you mean? >> Why you calling the police? >> Because,
bro, I wanted her to go away. I want her to learn about that.
>> You've dipped your willie in that pudding about a thousand
times and you
>> Okay, never mind. It's a homeless kick streamer. It's
a homeless kick streamer who's going to press Shuy on his uh
on his content model. Let's go, I guess. Is that Cowbot? I don't
even know who that is, bro. They just Everybody is streamer now
in Austin. What the [__] >> Yes, bro. >> She
done made you nut. >> So, all you had to do was call Mer
and then they would have squabbled, run inside, grab your stuff,
get out the
No, that's just going to cause more >> No, it doesn't.
Cuz you get your stuff, you put it in the storage unit, put it
in your van, instead you call 911. >> I mean, bro, I just
wanted to deal with her the most formal way possible. And when
I did that, she >> What's the IRS number? >> Bro,
Cowboy, I don't think you really realize how crazy she is, bro.
Like, >> my ass, bro. >> What do you mean? I grew
up with it. >> So, so you suggested that they should just
never learn their lesson legally? >> She's not going to
learn her lesson from >> That's not how they learn their
lesson.
>> She'll never learn her lesson. She is apparently medicated.
That's the crazy >> She's not taking a nap. No, we we both
know that. We We both know she's not taking that nap. >> Okay.
Well, I'm not her therap
I can't stress how much we don't know anything now. It's just
so easy. It's so easy to just play it off on like a mental illness.
Oh, she was on medicated. It's so lazy.
H I'll just hit play. It's just like the racism thing. It's so
easy to be funny with racism. Okay. It's so easy. and just like
misogyny or if you're in a different space, if you're on TikTok,
misandry. Okay, I won't pretend this is like a one-sided thing.
Only guys do this. This is just a male-coded space. It's just
a male male like uh what would you say? Like a male favored space.
All right, I know that there's misandry out there in equal amounts.
I'm not going to say that it's unique, but damn, even when you're
medicated, you will still have the big swings from bipolar anyways.
You will and you can, but I don't know if this is a big swing
or not. Like, I have no indication that it was.
What I what I can say is Zena was probably emotional about the
end of her relationship. She she clearly was yelling at him.
Why did you say you cared about me? Why did you say that? Right.
That's like the end of a >> Like she needs to you know,
bro, if if the only way that I can walk out of the building is
by calling the cops, then I'm going to do that. Like >> if
if
that's really grow up with it, >> if that's really the
issue, right, why do you keep storing your stuff here and keep
coming back? Why not just use a storage unit or anything like
that?
>> J on his feminist arc. I listen,
it's not even feminism. It's just lazy. I'm on my arc against
like the laziest content imaginable.
>> If that's really grew up with it, >> if that's
really the issue, right, why do you keep storing your stuff here
and keep coming back? Why not just use a storage unit or anything
like that?
>> Oh, okay. Yeah. [laughter]
Yeah. Is this guy on his feminism arc just asking totally legitimate
questions? Hey, did you know that she like might have had problems
with you before this? Hey, were you like leaving your stuff here?
Hey, did you come and get your stuff that was like $100 total
and say it was $20,000? You tell me you got $20,000 of butt plugs
in this box. Shuy, you got $20,000 of butt plugs. Really? Are
you sure?
That's crazy. Is that like a bag of holding? Is there Is that
Is that a pocket dimension in there? What the [__]
are we doing? >> Honestly, I forgot to understand. >> He
went three baby daddies and has been married twice before.
>> That's what I came back for. The Bigfoot costume. Bigfoot
costume.
>> Mhm. You came up off of me and you you couldn't afford
last thing. Honestly, you're too stupid. >> Your wife has
three baby daddies and has been married twice before.
>> Chad. Chad.
>> Cowboy, get out of here. You stalk Nickel's wife and
Nicoli should beat your ass for stalking her. Cowboy, stop talking.
Stalking Ammo, you leech. Wait, is this guy stalking Amaranth?
What? Hold on. What?
What the Wait, I need the lore on this now. Well, we might have
to go catch up on the entire CX universe. All of these guys.
Okay, [clears throat] we might have to go catch up on all of
them. Yeah, he's a Yes, he's a chat stalker. Okay, what we used
to call these guys is future stars. Okay, stars in waiting.
You call them a stalker. They show up with a camera. These guys
are unironically the Austin Nightcrawlers. Okay, they're just
going to run. They're going to run in
This guy is This guy is a future Burger Planet. Okay, a star
in the making. Let's go. this man. Bro, I moved your boat and
your van like multiple times and I did all this gap. >> I
got zero dollars. >> What do you mean? I gave you you caused
more damage. >> You gave away the boat for free. So, you
weren't doing it for monetary value, but I did service to complet
>> and the things I paid you, you would have owed me. No,
but that's the thing. You were giving it to JJ for free. So,
you lost zero monetary value. >> Your wife has three. What
I lost was all my time and everything I did. >> She went
with three baby daddies and has been married twice. >> I
don't know what situation you think happened, bro. Bro, she literally
assaulted me for like >> a woman's head don't hurt. >> I
don't give a [__] She's blocking my >> You
could have called me and I would have played safety for you,
bro. >> She would have put the You don't understand, bro.
I'm not doing all that.
>> Oh, can we stop with this? Jesus, I can't even hear
though. >> I don't know why you're trying to par more damn
to the boat than you would have been. >> But you lost I
didn't pay. >> But you lost $0 for it. You gave the boat
to JJ for free. Meaning you lost zero dollars.
>> The damages are not yours because of the damages. That's
not worth keeping. I decided that I was going to go. >> So
what were you going to do if I just dropped it off in Miami and
JJ didn't? >> It would have been my responsibility. I would
have had to deal with it. >> Yeah. You would have been
paying hundreds of dollars a day. Cheapest marina in Miami. >> Oh,
wait. This is the guy Zeus got in the fight with on the boat.
Let's go. >> It was $106 a day. I would try to deal with
it myself.
I don't understand them.
>> Couple doggos.
>> But no, all I'm saying
>> hey, sorry, but uh complaint some of the residents here.
You guys are fine to hang out, but just try not to be around
people's patios. >> That's understandable. >> Did
they complain? >> Yeah, they said something about cameras
and yelling. >> Yeah, there's a cops here and so we were
recording that, but we stayed here because he they were talking
to him for like 30 minutes, something like that. >> The
cops like just >> Yeah. No, but I just got that right now.
on that. >> What's the mall cop here for?
They're literally just standing. They're just standing like they're
not even around people's patios. What the [__] are
you here for?
>> All right. Well, like I don't I don't know. What is
your like what what is your goal? Like are you saying you like
what are like >> No, I'm just The golden not brought up
the money. That's only $240.
>> It's not even about that. Like that's it's it's regardless
of that. That's all that I was able to get. She wouldn't let
me look in the closet for my clothes or the washer. >> Why
didn't you call the cops to get your stuff instead of >> Well,
I didn't want to do that, bro. I Why would I want to get the
cops involved if I didn't think that I would need to? >> You
just got the cops? >> Yeah, bro. I tried to do it without
them being here, but she that was basically my last option, bro.
>> Yeah. All you have to do is call a non- emergency. Hey,
I want to get my stuff break up. >> I mean, yeah, that
what I That's what I should have done, bro. >> That would
have avoided you losing 10K on her bond. >> But I Bro,
I'm not paying that. >> Why you press me like that? >> You
legally have to pay it. That's not pressed. That's >> I
don't have to pay for her bond. >> You can pay. Everybody's
saying you're the one who paid her bail. >> Bro, you're
believing chat trolls. I never paid her bail, bro.
>> No, that was definitely I 100% believe that it was Ice
Boseidon. Okay. 100%. Got to be Ice. Okay. Kimmy was like, "Hey,
Ice. I Hey, Paul, I need the credit card." And he was like, "How
many credit cards you need, babe? I got them all. I got all the
credit cards for >> Then that changes a lot. But like that
changes a lot.
You think I I pay her bail and I'm going to get her locked up
and then keep paying her bail, man. >> Oh, hell no, bro.
>> I actually did. I know, bro.
>> And it's not even about the value of >> Okay.
W This guy's humble. Yeah. No, you know what? Chat got me. Chat
got me with that one. My bad. >> Point is she I' I've had
to deal with this every time I'm around her. Her her and her
[__] >> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. So, in the future,
if you know that it's going to happen with the next girl. >> Yeah.
I just said could have potentially done that. But there's been
times where I've gone to get my [__] Nothing >> You
could even call me. I would have butter. I would >> Okay.
Well, it didn't happen, bro. So, it's already over now. She's
She's packed up, bro. >> I came here to stream the movie
and then all of a sudden my chat's like, "Should we be a cop?
Should we cop beat up?"
Just as like I said, you right next to someone's someone like
lives here. So as long as you guys >> Oh, I see. My bad.
I thought >> No, my original I was just coming stream the
movie, but then everybody was like getting beat up.
>> Is the guy on the left? This guy Shuy. Yes, Shuy's making
a lot of money doing this. Shuy makes a ton of money. Shuy makes
all the money in the world. Okay. This guy's rich as
>> I think they were expanding.
>> Wait, can you carry that on your bike? >> No,
I don't know what I'm going to do to be honest. Uh, where's your
>> I was going to Uber. My van is at my
>> I guess maybe I could actually.
>> Are they still shooting the movie or >> I believe
we have a scene that we have to go somewhere to nearby, >> but
um maybe Paul will let you put it inside his gate area. >> Yeah,
I don't know. I mean, I kind of want to maybe go over there anyway
and see bloody scenes or something. >> We mostly
Okay. All right. I think this is uh this is pretty much it for
this part. Now we got Murk going live. I think we have a Darius
time stamp for when he was live talking about this a little bit.
Let me see. I got I know I got a time stamp. Okay, I know I do.
I just got to figure out where How do I find this VOD real quick?
Give me a
[sighs and gasps] Let me Dude, I can't type. What is wrong with
me? We'll watch Darius talk about it a little bit. Okay. And
then where do we go from there? We got Darius talking about it
[clears throat] and then we got the Merc conversation as well.
Okay. Give me a second.
Let me find What was my time stamp here? Hour 5:30. Let's check
it out. Oh, hold on. I need water. My voice is about to crack.
Jesus.
>> It's very close. >> Today. Bam. Bam.
Do you want me to look? >> Yeah. Go look that up.
>> From today or previously? >> Why are most C X
members kind of gay? I don't care. But man,
>> no. No, no, no, no, no. In the Purple Army Discord.
Join the Discord because here's the thing. I heard them yesterday
arguing about who had possession of a
because Shuvi owns a gun. >> Why can't someone in his Discord
real >> Someone said check Discord. Maybe check my Discord.
He's posting clips or forwarding clips and I I'm like a 99% sure
that she cuz she cuz she was
>> Oh no.
>> Yo, send that to my lawyer. I need that right now. Send
that to me privately. Send that to me privately. >> Dude,
all [clears throat] of these people think unironically
that if somebody does a crime, it means you're not guilty of
a crime. That's like that's unironically the thought process.
It's so goofy. Oh. Oh my god. God, this is going to GET ME OFF.
THAT PERSON JUST ASSAULTED SOMEONE. That means it's okay to assault
them at any other time. Oh my god. I'm I'm I'm clear. I'm I'm
in the clear. I'm totally free. >> Okay. You have 1.6 miles.
Amazing.
>> I need that. I need that.
>> Ah, poor E. I actually do feel bad for her actually,
but like I also don't really There's day.
>> I get it.
>> I mean, it's on video. >> No, it's not. I have
to read her boxes.
>> Wait, wait.
>> She got arrested.
>> Oh. Oh,
bro.
Kerbafine, really? Kerbine, you're sitting here, bro. Have some,
bro. She got no
pride whatsoever. Oh, no. Kerbine's with him again,
bro. What? Dude, no shot. No shot,
dude.
Wasn't Wasn't the girl wasn't did the Dayquil girl just threatening
to fight Kerbine like two days ago? What is happening? Is this
the girl with the rich parents? Yes,
she sends assassins after Dayquil. Damn.
Wait, where is Dayquil? What happened? Did she take the puppy?
I don't know. She took him shopping today,
[laughter] bro. What?
Listen, everything's coming up. Darius. Okay. Dayquil got into
a car accident. No shot. Wait, there's no way. There's no way
that Dayquil got into a car accident. And so Darius was like,
"Well, I need someone to hang out with today." Hey. Hey, Kerafine.
What are you doing? That didn't happen, did it? There's no possible
way. Get the Get all the way the out of here. No shot.
Broke four ribs. Okay. Okay. Can I get a time stamp? Where did
you learn this or is this just Discord logs? Cuz if this is talked
about on a stream somewhere, I need I need it. Okay. I need proof.
I need proof. >> She got arrested. >> Hey, man. He
did something I could never
>> It's That's bad for her though. Like bad. Like that's
not like because of her current case with uh Murk.
>> I don't know. I don't know. I don't Also, she's
[clears throat] >> her PR pond is removed
now.
And you know what that means?
>> That her that's a that Okay. If her PR bonds removed,
her her last thing was like $10,000.
Like, bro, that's not going >> there's video that he's
going to submit. Why were they even fighting?
Why else does she
Why else would she ever Dude, come on, dude. Are you guys being
serious?
Who's driving? Is Darius driving or is Kerbopene driving? Cuz
one of them is wildly violating the rules of the road right now.
He's like looking over and analyzing clips and reacting and she's
looking them up on her phone. So if he's not drive, he has to
be driving, right? Cuz if he was not driving, there's no way
he looks over and says, "Hey, look that up right now." >> I
didn't Can you send that to me privately, though?
>> She's pregnant with his kid. I don't think she's >> got
it. Darius is driving. >> That was this morning. >> One
second. >> I don't know. It's got to be like >> I
mean, it's daytime, but it's also a different time zone. >> No,
it's not. I threw your boxes.
>> We pondering. We pondering.
>> What was the other video? >> He's [__]
my uncle for this. >> Yeah, I know he is.
the [__] >> bro. I think they're Yeah, they're
just in traffic. Crazy.
>> It's not as bad. They're going to stop
>> butt plugs. Yeah, that's that's the cycle. The thing
is is it's like, oh, it's like, oh, funny. Like, I'm going to
ruin your cuz she she knows he's going to post it. So, she's
like, oh, if I say you're into butt plugs, it'll make you look
gay and you're a 19-year-old boy and you don't want to be seen
as gay, so maybe it'll >> Oh, that might be true. Why did
he He leaned into it really hard though. He said he was going
there to get his butt plugs, right? He said these were like the
butt plugs. I guess he's trying to just lean into it. Make it
absurd. >> Not a great strategy. >> Watch. Not going
to lie, but also like I shouldn't be sad at all. >> You
shouldn't be sad. This is very good for your case. [laughter]
>> It's good for my case, but I don't
>> dude like how like should be live. Oh, so that was right
now. Oh, it's 4:00 in >> Yeah. Well,
it's five o'clock, but it would probably just happen like
>> I don't know how long they talk about this for. Plant
dad, you would have watched this. Plant dad, you would have watched
this. Do you know how long they talk about this for?
>> He filed charges. There's a case. >> I know you're
feeling mad already. >> Like
talking the cops on stream. >> Yeah, of course. I'm so
tell
Shuy to call me. This raps for her. Like that's like over. Like
you have she has >> he's muted on stream because he's talking
to the cops. She has two court cases, one for domestic and the
other for whatever.
>> Dude, I love that Darius has like an encyclopedic knowledge
of the court system. Okay, experiential. He's got that extreme
dad experiential knowledge. Okay, that's you can't beat that.
He knows everything now. He has experienced it. Okay, he knows
he knows the cold hand of justice. Okay.
>> Uh and she was out on a PR bond. >> We have seven
miles before uh we want to get over >> I think. Right.
Was she even out on a pure bond? She wasn't out on a pure >> I
don't think she was. I think the theory was that he he paid for.
>> No, she No, she got out on a pure bond on her other
two cases. >> Get over to Laura. You have six. >> So,
I know for a fact she got paid. I think they already talked about
pay for it. Nerve baller paid for it, but yeah, other people
help pay for she. She was she was getting I'm [clears throat]
sure it was beautiful. I'm sure he pushed her. I'm sure she started
getting his face and like he put her away and she started swinging.
That's usually not work. She never hits first,
but
>> no way. [laughter]
extreme dad listening in the chat. Okay. Hadn't talked at all
today. I just knew he was here. Okay. [laughter] >> Started
recording her doing it and it's like at that point you're done.
>> She never hits first. >> She never hits first.
It's always like her getting in your face and like closing you
to the point like where you have to like literally pay her >> and
she thinks that he's like in love with her. So she's like, "Oh,
you have to call police." >> Yeah. She's in jail.
>> All right.
>> Good player. >> Yeah. Tyson's gone.
Uh, no. I'm not employed or I guess I'm self-employed or something.
Emergency contact. Oh, yes.
>> Oh my god. E N I N O
Here. Um, >> I should go look for clips or something. I
don't know. I don't know how long we watch this for. I don't
know how long we carry out this one for.
>> You know, like try like kind of
>> Okay, they listen to this for a little
>> and then she went in the closet or in the uh >> broke
dirty macking pawn once again.
>> Look, it's trying like outside.
Dude, there's going to be highlights from this. Bro, this is
like the biggest
This is going to be like the biggest blow up when it happens.
This is going to be crazy how this blows up.
Oh, it's going to be wild. All right. Where are your minions
with the timestamps? Uh, Plantad said he didn't watch it much
longer. Plantad usually has timestamps cuz he watches and then
he didn't watch much longer. They're not minions, though. They're
people. They're people who like content. Okay, don't be a
All right. Where are we going next? The Merc stuff. Hold on.
The Mark stuff is next. We'll keep looking around. Okay. Okay.
Okay. Mark stuff right here. So, apparently Mark started talking
about it right at the start of her stream. Okay. >> From
what I know, >> bro. Her music is loud as
>> Wait, I thought Darius was with Merc again. Not really.
No. Darius is farming these people for for content, for money,
right? He just keeps farming these people. He's making a lot
of money from >> Bash County is still ongoing.
Um,
like I said, I want >> They were never together again,
>> but I've been cooperating.
Um, they are supposed to uh
keep me up to date with stuff. The last thing I did was give
them my victim statement and
tell them if I wanted to like testify.
So, that is where we're at. >> So, this is with regards
to Merk's assault. Now, give me a second. Let me see if I can
find somewhere on the internet. Oh, you know what I should start
doing? I should start like quote tweeting all of these clips
when they come out because I need to keep them
on hand. I want to watch just for the fun of it. Okay, for the
heck of it, I do want to watch the Merc versus Zena assault again.
Okay.
Yeah, this one. This the whole thing.
Yeah, this is the whole thing. Well, it's it's pretty short.
Hold on. So, this is Murk is talking about cooperating with the
police over her assault by Zena, which is this right here. Okay,
it's this one right here.
>> So, MC Murk was getting all up. She was like grinding
on Shuy. She was like saying crazy to Shuy. She was grabbing
on Shuy and Zena wasn't there. But Zena did not like that. Okay.
>> Why? Because you're done with me. Because I just owned
you in about five. >> I didn't I forgot about this guy
over in the cuff chair. That's crazy. [__] >> Were
you packaging? >> Oh [__] Oh [laughter] [__]
Everybody leave. Everybody leave. Holy. Oh, hell no. What the
[__]
Oh my god. No. What the [__]
Oh, is that the whole thing? Now that's not the only clip. Where's
the one where she goes, "Oh, you uh
>> what does she say to him exactly?" Or what does she
say to Mark exactly? You're not so tough now, right [__]
Or some [__] like that. There's more to the clip.
No,
there's no way I can't I can't be creating phantom memories.
She totally has to. There's more to the clip.
Where is it? I could have sworn she like throws Yeah. You tall,
huh? She like throws a
me Korea man on the sidelines.
>> Everything's on stream. Have I touched >> you
wrote on me, bro? >> Okay. Oh my god. >> Stop, bro.
>> Oh my god. Stop. >> This is what sets scene off.
>> Okay, stop. >> You're asking me to stop? >> Yes.
Okay, >> bro. Can you just get out of my bed, >> I
thought y I thought y'all were the squeeze, bro. >> What
the [__] happened to the squeeze
>> What the
reverse? This is so bad. Yeah, bro. >> He's laying in bed
trying to sleep. >> This is actually bad. >> You
smell good.
>> Here we go. I think this is
>> The sound is sound.
The sound is okay.
>> OH MY GOD. >> SHOOT ME. >> BREAK IT OUT.
BREAK IT OUT.
>> BRO, STOP. >> GET THE [__] OUT. >> GET
OUT, DOG.
>> Break it. Oh my god, >> dude. Dude, I just keep
What is the
You just hear like flesh on flesh. JUST WHACK WHACK WHACK.
>> SOLID IS OKAY.
>> CALL THE COPS. WE CAN TELL YOU SEXUALLY HARASSED PEOPLE.
>> I got what I wanted. Yeah, I know.
>> Yeah, I got what I wanted. I got what I wanted. Dude,
that that was the craziest thing to me was Burke talking actually
talking about how she was hoping Zena would come and assault
her and then she's like not fighting back. She just gets like
ragd dollled because she actually wanted to be assaulted so she
could press charges for Darius. Now I know for a fact, okay,
Darius is going to appreciate that. He's going to show you real
love now, Mark. 100%. Now that you have entrapped in and now
that you have like accepted this assault, I I get it. Okay, I
get it. I know.
Surely he's going to he's going to take you back now. Kerbof,
watch out. Kerbine, how many people have you gotten beaten up
for or by for Darius? Okay, Kerbine could never. She's this preppy
rich girl. She could never tank a a Zena assault for Darius's
sake. All right. Wouldn't happen.
>> Is that Korea? I don't even know what that is. >> Now
he's Now she's punching him next. >> Good content to my
boy Benny. Thank you.
>> Just let me drive.
>> Just let me [__] guy say
you guys. She said she's not going to talk to anyone. That could
work out.
>> Don't make me restrain you. Don't make me restrain you.
Oh, she's trying to bite me now. You are
>> Clearly, you're unhinged. And do you think that I'm
afraid of you?
>> Guess what? And I'm fat. And I got out of the prison
stream first. And look at you. And look at what you are.
>> OH [screaming]
NO. GROSS. What is with these people?
Can you guys just punch other people? Just punch them. Stop with
the spitting. The spitting's gross. Okay, they're all camels.
I prefer llamas. Okay, but yes, they're all camels. Llamas. Some
form of I don't even know what that genus is called. Okay, but
every time, man.
See, this is I will say amateur technique. Okay, Darius would
never do this. Darius when he hawks a Lugie, it is one consistent
coherent piece. Okay, Darius is like Darius is something like,
you know, Cal Ripken when it comes to hawking luggies. Okay,
he's like he's he's legendary. He's the most consistent there's
ever been. Okay, this guy can spit 20 feet and hit somebody in
the eye. All right,
Merc totally amateur. She's spraying everywhere. This is a shotgun.
This is birdshot right here. Okay, Darius is a sniper. Murk rock
and birdshot. Okay, if this guy was more than 3 ft away, he wouldn't
even get hit. >> No, M. Wow. See, just >> I don't
tolerate that. >> Keep going. Keep spitting. Keep
>> Just keep spitting. Just keep spitting. Just keep spitting.
Keep spitting.
>> Okay, that's awesome. That's an awesome meme. Okay,
I feel like I fed that when we watched that clip. Okay, I was
putting that out there. I played the Stone Cold music. It was
awesome. All right, ZENA NATION, LET'S GO. THE POP OFF FROM THE
CROWD. OKAY, the pop off from the crowd when Zena enters the
ring. Everybody hates her until she until she ratchets up. >> I
just got a text and he said yes. So, >> we're the same.
[gasps]
>> I did go see her that night because I was trying to
get her to hit me and I walked by Pat. I want to go. I want to
go MY [screaming]
>> DUDE. Zena's uh Zena's awesome content. >> She
is awesome.
>> You were paid. Were you paying? Did you enjoy it?
And I keep giving your WHOLE
clean off.
>> It was funny though. >> Stay under you fighting
for [clears throat] some storming on you like a [laughter]
>> dude. I'm retweeting that. That's awesome. That was
an awesome edit. Who did that?
That was awesome. There's
a nerd baller. Damn, that was cool.
That's crazy. Shouldn't do that. That's not content. Assault
is not content. Okay. Well, it is, but it's like not repeatable
good content. Okay.
Don't assault people. Assaulting people is bad. Actually, I know
a lot of people don't understand this, but assaulting people
is actually bad.
Okay. All right. So now we've got Merc. So she was saying Murk
was saying based on that incident, Merc is cooperating with the
police. I don't understand how Zena gets out of that incident.
That incident is pretty open and shut. All right. She runs in,
she beats the out of MC multiple times, maybe.
>> I'm sure with her being um incarcerated,
>> it'll definitely make my case easier.
so we shall see.
Shuy told the police Zena forced him to have sex, too. Um, it's
a little it's a little um ironic
because didn't she? She made like a a really long tweet about
me assaulting Shuy. Falsely, of course. She made a big deal about
the whole interaction between me and >> No, you were like
totally groping on Shuy. And for her to sit here and force someone
to have sex with her
>> kind of makes you look uh hypocritical
>> every single time
[clears throat] >> cuz she was that was the hill she chose
to die on. She wanted people to know that I assaulted Shuy.
>> She wanted
people to know that. So for her to be accused of that by Shuy,
it's it's interesting.
I thought she was against assault. I thought that was one of
the worst things you could do. >> They say Zena forced
foreign objects into his while he was sleeping. God >> Is
that true?
>> Is that true?
>> That's wild.
>> Like I said, men can get assaulted, too. It's not just
women. So, if that's true and what he's told to the police is
true, I I hope he is okay. I hope he, you know, can do what's
best for him.
>> you think Darius got fingered, too? Uh, unlikely. Cuz
here's the thing about Zena. She does tend to reveal that stuff
when it when Push comes to shove. And I'd say Push has come to
shove with Darius multiple times. She never mentioned it. In
fact, I would say that's what makes it far more damning for Shuy
is the fact that she never once said any of this about Darius
in any of their blow-ups. Didn't say it about Sneo. Didn't say
it about anybody,
like like it's a uniquely Shuy thing. So I I don't know.
That's the weird thing for me is like if Zena had a pattern of
like making this up, I would get it. But she doesn't. Not Not
with regards to that at least.
>> Um I don't know. I feel like
>> I mean it's believable. Like
>> if you are someone who has a certain >> it will
just be your pay. >> Oh, hold on. Hello. >> Reuben
donated $3. Do you think she was gentle or did she just shove
it in
>> Okay. Thank you very much, Reben Ruben. Godamn Reuben
Rubin again. Another banger. Thank you very much. >> Appreciate
it. >> Oh, guys, I've not chilled a single time during
this stream. Guys, if you like the content, go ahead and donate
a couple bucks. You can add more time to the stream. Okay. Uh,
subs don't knows. You can sub on kick. All right, we are
We got to be
like four subs. Four subs from another hour on the stream. Let's
go.
>> Oh, no. Sorry, not four. Three subs. Three subs from
another hour on the
>> in my opinion, I don't know the goings on of their private
relationship, but she doesn't seem like the type of person to
like want to put his ass.
And we all know Zena uses toys. So, if he did spend 20k on toys,
then um, you
>> it's probably for Zena.
>> And I will not have anyone supporting Zena in my chat.
So, if um
If you're going to sit here and make excuses for her or defend
her, you
>> debate the Xeno defenders, MC. Debate the Xeno Defenders
now. >> See your way out. >> That's free content.
>> Yo, what's up, Platt?
>> Um, but yeah, like I said, I've heard of situations
before where women will try and force themselves on people to
keep people from breaking up with them or leaving them.
>> you know, a lot of women use that as their weapon, like,
"Oh, you won't break up with me if uh, you know, I suck your
dick right now." Or, "Oh, you won't break up with me if uh, I
do this." And believe it or not, that is a form of assault. So,
if that's what she did to him, that's she assaulted him. And
we shouldn't be laughing about it. And I've noticed a trend where
people will laugh at men coming out about their stories. Oh,
this woman touched me. This woman hurt me. This person did this.
And people laugh at them.
>> And it's really common with students. Like you've heard
stories of teachers violating their students and
people laugh like, "Oh, I wish that was my teacher." Or, "Oh,
I would let my teacher touch me. That's not
>> okay." But she didn't meet Shuy when he's a minor. That's
like a big difference. And there was no power imbalance there.
In fact, Shuy was probably the bigger streamer. Shuy probably
had the like more professional success than her.
What? Where? this like oh it's kind of like this except in every
single way that it's not at all.
>> If someone feels
violated >> nice guys kind of like there's a power imbalance
there. How he's the bigger streamer professionally and he's an
adult in terms of life experience in terms of experience maybe
but it seems like in a whole bunch of other ways Zena was the
person with less power in that
>> When's the next Nick White stream snipe? Here's the
thing.
Um, someone sent me the clip from Hannah's stream
>> about me about being scared.
>> Yeah, I was over the top, but
>> I'm not like menacing. I'm not like >> Wait, what?
>> What the >> Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. Where's
the clip from the Wait, Hannah Rididgeway reacted to Merc or
what? There's like a Merc clip from Hannah Rididgeway. Is that
who she's talking about right there? I checked that out.
We'd have to see it.
All right,
that is just about everything. So, there's one other piece of
content here that we could go to. Let me see here. There's Shuy
talking to Zena yesterday. Sorry. Yeah, yesterday.
So, Shuy calls her.
They have like a whole conversation.
He says he's wants he wants to go over and pick his up.
Oh, this is the the Nick White cos thing. Okay. Okay. Yeah, we
we did see some of that.
Um, I
am trying to retrieve my property.
>> Yeah, that's nice. I said I'm trying to retrieve my
property.
My BB gun.
No, I did not take that.
You have it.
You're the one that has it.
>> I don't know where you put my
Oh, [__] god. So, I Yeah, you do expect me to go
sit there and look through everything to find. I didn't >> Oh,
I mean, unless you want to let me in to look for my belongings,
then yes, I expect you to look and find my belongings so that
I can retrieve them.
>> This is two days ago. >> The last place it was.
So if it's not there then >> you need the clothing basket.
>> No, instead you gave me lies. Can you help me with [__]
like oh you know I meant everything that I said when I said it
before blah blah blah. But clearly >> what does that have
to do with you getting your belongings? You got your belongings.
You didn't even have to pay. You didn't even have to pay. >> Have
attitude [__] I am allowed to have attitude. >> You
didn't even have to pay to get your stuff personally handed to
you.
Now I got to [__] stop it,
>> bro. I don't I listen, I get some of this stuff from
you guys, but like
everybody in these situations is crazy.
you see like two crazy people. You see two hobos fighting the
street. You're like, you see one of them is like black and you're
black. You're like, dude, the black guy's totally in the right.
The black guy couldn't possibly do anything wrong. It's really
funny. Like that's how you guys react to this stuff. Um it's
all crazy women. Nope. Crazy people on both sides every single
time. >> I mean I said unless you want me to come look
for my own.
>> I don't want to be on your dumb ass.
>> My My hobo who's biting like who's taking fullon like
bites out of the other hobo. My hobo is less insane. Actually
my hobo's based
>> because they share an identity group with me. My hobo
is so based.
Did he let her know? I don't even know if he let her know that
he was streaming
Oh, disavow. She's trying to get She's trying to get streams
merckked. Okay. What the
Totally disavow.
Bro, this is like too chill.
Music's too chill. I got to switch up music. kind of go back
to the classic
this kind of music
less less chill. Okay,
>> Let's see. Okay.
to say those things and get me banned.
She's still on the phone cuz I think
she should still be on the phone, I think.
Or she calls back. I'm not sure
I'm going 30 seconds forward. Okay,
there's her calling back right here.
And then he mutes.
Okay, here's him unmuting. Give me a
>> There we go.
>> Bro, obviously the only reason you use those words is
because you're on like I'm sorry, but Shuy totally planned to
have a confrontation there and gets it put in jail. Like 100%
right.
Like I'm sorry. He 100% was trying to make this happen. As much
as I like obviously Zena trying to stop him from going down the
stairs or whatever, trying to stop him and have that conversation.
Not good. But I fully believe Shuy knew that she was upset that
he went over there. He could have like content in a fight.
>> It doesn't make it okay, but it does make it like >> Oh,
you're literally 30. >> I don't I don't feel as bad for
him when he does this. Okay. What the [__] you >> It's
muted.
Disavow. Although it didn't get all the way out. Okay. That That's
why Zena wins every single time. Okay. It's muted. Okay. Okay.
Let's go.
Oh, what? What?
Wait. Why didn't this play?
>> Oh, it didn't play. What the?
All right. I think they keep talking here a little bit.
>> Are you
>> okay? I guess I'm
>> Well, yeah, we do know that. >> Yeah. Yeah, we
know that
>> you called me for a [__] favor, dude. >> Yeah,
I asked you if you could retrieve my properties. >> Cool.
It doesn't matter. If you call me, you should automatically know.
Have your focus muted. I don't want to deal with
>> Okay. I mean, how did what what how did you even know
I was live? How did you even know I was live?
>> I literally called you and it wasn't on
>> but then you started giving me attitude acting out for
the stream. That's why I put it on speaker. >> Yeah, cuz
you assumed that you were on stream cuz you were watching my
stream
>> No, I have open I have open eyes
>> Okay, 100%. That's why the second I say something about
you, you text me, right? Yeah, I opened your stream after I got
off the phone with you because clearly you're balling while on
stream. Yeah, I >> at 4:40 you texted me 1 minute after
I said something about you.
>> Oh yeah, earlier I >> Oh yeah, you were watching
my stream. Okay, if
you don't want to give me my property, that's fine. I will just
get my full find replacements.
>> All right. Well, I'm I don't I don't need to continue
to talk. >> I mean, he knew Zena was watching. Okay. Of
course he does watch it. >> I only called you to see if
you could give me my stuff. >> Because you want me to look
for it. >> It's your my [__] Yes. That you
took out of my car and put somewhere in your house. I don't know
where you put my
>> I don't know where you put my property. You took it
out of my car. I don't know where you put it. >> You were
using it in >> He is explicitly just trying to force a
fight so that he can have content or get a protective order.
I'm not sure which. Like it's so
ah it's so disingenuous. It's so gross. >> You took it.
Oh, okay. Oh, okay. Right.
>> Oh, okay. For sure.
>> That's nice. Pointing it at your head. Okay, bro. >> It's
a [__] toy. YES, YOU PUT A TOY. YOU PLAY WITH A TOY.
WHERE DID YOU PUT >> INTERESTING. INTERESTING. WELL, I
mean, I didn't I didn't put that in your
>> It was actually in my car.
It was in my car. It was in my car in my glove box and you removed
it.
>> So, Jinger is saying that he asked her to get it out
of there. Apparently, >> I already told you I don't know
where it is. You put it somewhere. >> Also, who keeps a
butt plug in their glove box. What the That's where gloves go,
man. >> You don't know how to find it. >> I can come
look for it. If you don't want me to look for it, then that's
fine. I'm not going to continue to talk about this for no reason.
>> But where is it?
>> I mean, I obviously don't know where it is. Like I said,
>> I'm not going to keep talking about this, man. Cue cue
a clip from 5 minutes earlier where he says, "I got to get my
property back." And he calls her directly and then then she's
like, "Oh, she's talking about it. Well, I'm not going to keep
talking about this, man. I'm not going to keep doing this. This
is stupid >> times, but I guess have a nice day." >> Talk
about other stuff, too. with it.
>> Um, if you don't want to look for it, that's fine. Again,
I don't know where it is. So,
yeah, if you can't find it, then I guess it is what it is.
>> Why don't you just look in the
>> Well, I think isn't she saying she doesn't know where
it is?
>> It's not there.
>> Also, I'm not there.
>> It's definitely not there. I did.
>> Is that in the car with you? Bro, it's not here. Why
do you think I asked you? You think I would contact you if I
had it? >> Yeah, because sometimes you don't look for [__]
>> Okay. Well, uh, I do not have it. That's why I texted
you asking for it.
>> Yeah, you probably didn't even look for it. It's probably
your [__] but Okay.
>> Okay. I mean, I don't know why you're trying to make
this a big deal. It's very simple. I just asked you if you could
find my property and hand it to me. Yes.
>> Bro, what the
what are these roads?
>> Or do >> Yeah, I asked for your stuff just like
you asked for mine. Just like you asked for your What are you
talking about? >> Like what the
>> There are a lot of people Yeah. who stream without this
stuff.
Stream without it shaking this badly. >> Leverage or controling
again. But I mean, I don't even
Hold on.
There we go.
Isn't this bannable streaming driving on the phone or driving
with your stream running? No, it's not. Although I don't know
if he Oh, no. He does have a mount here. I think they do let
people mount up their uh their devices or whatever.
Annoying, but it is what it is, man.
Where is this a suspension? Like like having your camera mounted
in your car while you drive. Everybody does this. Like literally
this is tons of streams. What are we talking about?
I think he has a stable phone holder, but there's like the van
is just shaking. Like the van suspension doesn't work. Yeah.
>> All right. Don't do not sticker crazy, bro. They weren't
lying. Don't not do it, bro. I tell you. [__] It's
never worth it.
>> He's looking at the camera all the time. He's reading
the chat is what he's doing. He's not looking at the camera as
much as he's reading the chat and they happen to be right like
overlapping almost, right? The camera and the phone >> calling
again. But I mean, I don't even care. I'm not going to I didn't
call to argue. I'm good. >> You don't, >> dude. The
crazy thing is is he's like looking at the chat while answering
on a second phone, his personal device, while answering that
phone and like looking at messages from Cena. He's like double
fisting phones while driving. He's He's not just texting while
driving. He's like double texting while driving. >> My
[__] so I'm good.
I'm not platforming you. I'm good. I'll take my L, I guess. I
mean, the BB gun costs like $50. I don't really care that much.
You know what I'm saying?
So, surely because he doesn't care that much, he dropped it,
right? He totally dropped it.
Okay, so there's the reference to the BB
That's what Darius was talking about earlier when he was like,
"Oh, they argued about having a gun." Dude, why does everybody
do the I I never watched this. I've never watched this before.
When they when they like do,
right? I don't know. It's
Darius literally I guess Darius doesn't do that. Darius was literally
like, "Put that on right now. I want I want all my Zena updates."
[laughter] Cuz he was very aware of this. He was discussing this
and saying, "Oh yeah, I think Zena had a gun and we're worried
about like how that would affect her probation and [__]
Maybe she found it. Yeah, right. She ended that call and went
straight to my stream to see what I said. Heard some she didn't
like and called right back cuz she wanted to yell at me and say
what? Say what? Say what? Say more things that are not true.
We We call this the Hassan [__] Gringle. This is
This is literally just the Hassan [__] Okay. Precisely.
Uh I don't watch this stuff. Drama is like really for for like
people who don't touch grass. for total losers. Plays out the
minutia. Knows like Destiny Orbiters with like 20 viewers. Knows
Destiny Orbiters with 30 viewers. I don't know anything about
this person, but here's like a really niche drama with this like
30 viewer streamer. Okay. Oh, good one. Good one, buddy.
He's demonic, bro.
They will try to destroy you just if you do not choose them,
bro.
They will try to destroy you just for not picking them.
>> He [laughter]
It's just so lazy. It's so lazy. It's very funny. Okay.
They'll try to destroy you. Yeah, it was me who called. Yeah,
it was me who's like trying to get $50 in property back and repeatedly
maintaining contact. But these will try to destroy you. Okay.
They they'll just try to destroy you. There's nothing you can
do. They'll just try to destroy you,
>> I swear to God.
You should you should feel bad if this kind of like rhetoric
if this kind of like way of speaking works on you. Just guy does
a whole laundry list of bad things. Um that is a she's a crazy
she's a crazy and then you're like yeah what an evil person.
What an evil person. God, it's so lazy.
Like people don't even care that they have the reverse. Sorry,
this is actually setting me off cuz I Where else do we run into
this? Oh, like Fantes does like red pill talking points now.
Everybody does this cuz it's like the laziest, easiest in the
whole world. Okay, it is so dumb. But everybody, it's like invading
all my content. I can't watch content without people being like,
"And don't forget women are to steal all your money every single
time. Every single time."
Ah, it's ruining everything. So, when I see it, I have to call
it out. You You guys are like the Tik Tok people, okay? You guys
are just the inverse of the Tik Tok people here on kick. Like
the CX viewers by and large, it's just the inverse of the Tik
Tok people. Like all the people who think everything's toxic
masculinity, you're just those people. Like precisely.
Very gross. Very gross. We continue. Oh, no. We don't continue
cuz he's done talking about it.
We We don't love women. I just said, "I hate the Tik Tok women
who say everything's toxic masculinity, who can't stop talking
about how everything men do is bad." Those people all suck, too.
Unfortunately, it's like 90% of society between those two camps
and like 10% in the middle who are like, "Wait, you guys understand?
You're like,
it's like two sides of the same coin. It's like two two parts
of a hole. Like you, why are you doing this? Why do you guys
all hate each other? It's crazy.